hey how's it going what is your name it
was your question my name is Jill a
creator of the Luna Vachon
um Scott I read it clear it changed my
life
thank you I'm Andy I'm thank you you got
continuously screws out of getting an
Emmy anyway my question you know we live
in the country where you can get gunned
down from in broad daylight but looking
to blood and in regards to this show and
his fandom in spite of careful
cultivation and palpable chemistry and
blatant close-ups
some were shocked that Rick and Michonne
consummated what they already had going
as far as to say you know she's like his
sister or even more bizarre like his
daughter um
the erasure of the dark-skinned black
woman is what this show is challenging
with Michonne and they've treated her
with dignity she's not fetishized she's
no one's cheating and the audience
particularly black girls and women
everywhere can see her be nurturing love
one screen and not be the funny sexless
sidekick so thank you profusely for that
saying of course my question is were you
aware the full political impact this
would have and can we please for the
love of God have a rashon photoshoot
who wants answer that you want answer
that scattered us I hear me you owe me
Oh big he said okay airplane you know
why don't we tag-team this okay um
you know what I wasn't aware that it
would have the impact that it did and I
think I think it's because I I was
thinking these guys as characters that I
was thinking of these guys as I don't
even like using the term guy it's kind
of pen kind of patriarchal there I like
thinking of these people the I think one
of the fantasies that we all share about
the apocalypse is a lot of the things
that separate us a lot of the BS that
has been hoisted on us by society falls
away and that people are just measured
as who they are
men women any any background you have
and and seeing all these people as who
they are is I don't know it's it's been
a dream to tell these characters without
the hang-ups of society on top of them
tonight you better than that no I mean I
think honestly I am I am really actually
simply thankful for mr. Gimbel because
he is a true consummate storyteller and
I think that's at the core of of
everything because when you're dealing
with a real storyteller they're not
paying attention to what you know has
societally happened or what other
portrayals have existed or the the
stereotypes because they're not
interested in that they're interested in
the humanity interested in in what's
truly happening and what's what connects
and what's cohesive and what's organic
and so when I know look at what you know
mr. Gimbel does and how you can feel
like you are trusting yourself as an
artist to someone who is going to pursue
a true narrative and I think that's what
he did in this instance and it is a you
know I hear you I hear you on all fronts
you know um I have always been a black
girl so born that way
you know um this is true so I hear you
and and really it is you I remember when
I was in college I was in I did a course
on racial representation and media and I
was studying we were all studying
different different TV shows and how
they portrayed race knowingly or
unknowingly
and it was you know it was a pretty
unfortunate dismal portrayal of like a
data collection that we had at the end
of the day and I'm really really
thankful to be a part of a show where I
can really see that humanity is pursued
before any of that stuff and so you know
and I think that sometimes to change the
picture you usually see on the screen
can ruffle people because it's change
and change will always cause some people
to feel uncomfortable and that's okay
that's okay be patient with them and
take them along but you know it is it is
a something I'm deeply thankful for that
I'm a part of a narrative that
that pursues true narrative and doesn't
get caught up in that stuff and so you
know why not you know and I hope that it
actually I understand the validation
that is felt and as you mentioned I I
was watching the show I would feel it
but I hope and believe that this will
you know break that barrier and allow
more of these portrayals to be more
freely expressed that was a great
question that was a heck of a way to
kick it off hi what is your name
sir hi I'm Sean and what is your
question my question is for Norman
Reedus my boy well that's a surprise
yeah my question is what was your
favorite scene from season six and why
was it the scene where you blew negan's
men up with a rocket launch you know me
really well uh that was a lot of fun I
have to say and yeah I'm covered in
glitter yeah hello
what is it work honey what
that's the question okay um yeah that
was a blast I it was really really you
guys made out of like a Michaels you
know what Big Brother glitter oil no
Allen's the question for noon Ollie's
all he talks about when he was on top of
that tank was says how do I look for bed
it was hot I remember I thought my
eyelashes were bird on it was it was fun
I mean all the scenes on the show are
fun and you know it they're all cool
when you throw in a rocket launcher it's
just more fun it's all fun thank you
you're welcome
oh my god you're amazing what is your
name Danny
that is a WoW oh we have a good be
hammer recast I have a picture with that
kid you were just in Denver right oh man
what is your question and then can I
come down and take a picture with you
all you're asking it yeah so let's go
with the question how many zombies um
did you kill in this second episode of
Walking Dead
as finicky well the second episode in
which negan appears is what you're
saying and I'm going to give a spoiler
right now
negan does survive episode 1 what you
don't know I think you're up to their
call I you know it depends how you you
might actually here's another spoiler
for you
Tannen because negan is responsible for
the sanctuary where he is located we
will see a lot of walkers on a fence
outside of his compound so I am gonna
put the number and Greg would know
better than me at 61 walkers at least at
least thank you very much for your
question
you're amazing uh thank you for the
picture a couple more questions we have
about five or five minutes left what is
your name oh hey hey guys we didn't get
any of that it hello on screen yeah
you're not you're fine no one's out
having yeah it's a vegan um so a couple
years ago I did get bit by an infected
individual are you Lauren
a couple years ago anyway oh yeah thank
you for the walking for walkers
appreciate that the walking for walkers
a marathon really appreciate that but um
Mike my question is um with the
escalating violence in the new season
and just the stereotypes that we face
what can you guys offers the stereotypes
of walkers face you talking about your
standing up for Walker rights yeah I was
in here last year go ahead is she sorry
she did not interrupt you know I know JD
dress before the show is very
marginalizing to the undead do you have
a suggestion uh maybe show that we can
hold jobs steadily yeah what types of
jobs would that be a gas station perhaps
that's a teaching teaching G be teaching
your classroom speed-reading meat
mincing Oh
well thank you you're having opportunity
to talk to a walker don't break don't
break is really I will say that the the
Karen storyline deals a lot with this
stuff thank you for being here it's very
brave hey get up what some lady
oh hey but lady I was um well first of
all I want to say all these buttons are
the property of negan but my question is
claimed not laggin awesome I just want
to say you missed an opportunity to be
Eugene with that hair look at that
that's on you um my question is there
are so many people from Britain on the
cat in the cast
do you ever stand over on one side of
the set and say these Americans are
crazy and I miss our British food after
that last vote they had they're not
really allowed to do that oh damn
chocolate crew
the world droplet - yeah it's getting
crazy and turn into a madhouse in here
Chandler shut your eye here always we
have time for one more question it's
good to see you but lady thank you for
the buttons yesterday I appreciate it
last question go ahead sir yeah hi I'm
Daniel um Chris Hardwick you're a big
fan of the show you're a host of talking
dad host of this panel every year all
true when will you make a cameo on the
walking dead
Chris Chris Chris I feel honored I would
be honored to do Cassie
okay real quick real truth [ __ ] chair
on his offer come down and we'll make
you a walker like I couldn't just appear
on the show yeah you know I mean like
that'd be weird like I I didn't accuse
me enough of ruining walking dead I
couldn't do it for real if I were on the
show although I do think it'd be really
funny if at the end of a long day at
killing walkers like they come back to
Alexandria and I'm just on the living
room and I talk to them about how their
day went I think I get in bad that's all
I would love to be made as a walker I
think I would love to come into be a
wife but I just don't want I never want
to get in the way of the show so I
couldn't be recognized I would because
once you recognized me it kind of takes
takes you out of the show and I just I
want people to enjoy the show and I
don't have to be I don't wanna be the
reason people get angry so but I but I
will do it if that's okay with with
nikka Tarot if it was Scott okay great
I'm sure next season Chris Hardwick has
Shiva uh uh thank you says Karen Karen I
could be Karen yeah
hello Carol you're looking well so as
you want to remind you the season 7
trailer is up on YouTube October 23rd is
the date that's walking down a return to
your screens and then we're going to do
it all a new live talking dead right
after the premiere and then the seasons
a premiere Sunday August 14th I know
there was a lot of anticipation about
this panel I know there was frustration
at the end of season 6 I hope you know
we did the best job we can you guys
really have to understand you really
have to understand how much these people
care about you how much they care about
the fans how much they care about the
show no one's ever trying to mess with
you everyone's doing the best they can
and you know I hope we'll see you at the
start of season 7 and thank you for
helping us be a part of game days in
Germany another huge hand for everyone
on the panel
you